قال الرئيس الامريكي جو عبيد انه يعتقد ان
ادارته ستحصل من الكونجرس على التمويل
اللازم لدعم اوكرانيا وفي مؤتمر صحفي
مشترك مع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشيسوناك اضاف بايدن ان ثمت توافق في
واشنطن على ان روسيا لن تتوقف عند كيف
اعتقد اننا سنحصل على التمويل الضروري
لدعم اوكرانيا طالما استدعى الامر رغم
انكم تسمعون اصواتا في الكونجرس اليوم
تجادل بشان ما اذا كان علينا ان نواصل
تقديم ذلك الدعم والى متى ينبغي ان يستمر
اعتقد ان غالبيه زملائي بما فيهم النقاد
متفقون على ان روسيا لن تتوقف عند كيف
من جانبي قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشيسونا الروسيه تتطلب الرد واضاف ان
الدعم المقدم لاوكرانيا يبعث برساله الى
الرئيس الروسي مفادها ان الحلف لن يتراجع
الامر يتعلق بالردع الرئيس بوتين يعتقد ان
الحلف سيتعب ويستسلم ولكن ذلك لن يحدث
وكلما قدمنا دعما لاوكرانيا يدوم لسنوات
فذلك يبعث برساله الى بوتين باننا لن
نتراجع وسنواصل دعمها طالما استدعى الامر
ونامل ان يدفعه ذلك الى سحب قوته